So at the end of the
class, there are really
two major forms of assessment.
One is an online
written exam, which
is an exam where the questions
and the way to submit
the answers is fully online.
And that link is
unveiled, and then I
give three to four days for the
students to answer this exam.
It is an open book,
open internet exam.
They can use any materials they
want, but no collaboration.
So I don't have a formal
way to check for this
but essentially it's
an individual exam.
And by submitting
the answers online,
again using for example a
mechanism like Google Forms,
you can relatively quickly
compare the answers and grade
these exams very
efficiently and also see
if there's any patterns.
So this is a way to essentially
check individual learning
with all the materials at hand.
The way I structure
the online exam
is a mix of multiple-choice
questions, essay questions,
but also some calculations.
And the exam starts with
some very easy questions
that can be referenced
in readings or materials
in textbooks,
interpretive questions.
And then they get
progressively more difficult.
And the last two questions--
in one of the questions,
I give them a calculation
that they have to do that has
a very non-obvious answer.
And it's interesting to
see some students that
force an answer that's not
actually the right answer
because somehow they believe
that any question given
on an exam must have
this one correct answer.
And other students scratch
their heads and say,
I don't think this question
has the right answer.
And so it's a very
interesting thing
because, in the real world,
you often get requirements
from customers that are
unrealistic or can't
be fulfilled.
And so the purpose
of these questions
is to really get students
to think and connect
the material to
real-world situations
that they will encounter.
In the last question, I
then ask about systems
engineering-relevant things
that have happened that they
might have seen in the news.
So for example, one year I asked
about the Volkswagen emissions
scandal, which is very related
to system engineering, trade
offs between fuel efficiency,
cost, NOx emissions.
It's very much current affairs.
This year, I asked the
students about the problems
that Samsung experienced with
their Galaxy Note 7 batteries
and what is the root
cause of those problems.
And how are those problems
related to the material
that we teach in class?
So I recommend that one
of the last questions
connect the students
with things that they're
seeing in the news.
The oral exam is given either
in person in the same room
or through an online platform
like Skype or WebEx or Google
Hangouts.
The quality of the
online experience,
the image, the sound,
is generally so good
that there's virtually
no difference
between doing the oral exam
in person or over the web.
And the oral exam is anywhere
between 15 to 20 minutes
per student.
That doesn't sound
like a lot of time,
but with well-structured
questions you can learn a lot
and have a great dialogue
with the students.
I try to put the
students at ease.
It is more a discussion
than a classical exam.
Nevertheless, it's
a great way for them
to engage with the
material again,
to engage with us as
instructors and TAs,
and usually it sort of puts
a nice bow on the class,
and it's a nice finishing
touch to the class.
Logistically, the way
we do the oral exam
is we open up typically
one or two full days.
So I have to reserve
a couple of days
on my calendar just
dedicated to the oral exams.
And then there's
sign-up slots where
students can just sign up online
and show up at the right time.
And it's been
working pretty well.